agent ellen o'connor was used to working
normal cases in the department of
analytics
or at least as normal as cases can be
when you work for the scp
foundation this usually involved
analyzing data and managing the watchdog
network for critical surveillance
information
scp sites and facilities were highly
guarded and major dangers usually
stemmed from practical security failures
that would be dealt with on-site by
security teams
it was rare that she would be called
down to investigate a high priority
case in person but that's exactly what
happened
when she got an alert from the holding
facility containing
scp-5002 scp-5002 was not your usual
specimen
better known as emma hastings she was a
seemingly normal woman born in tewksbury
england
where she worked as a writer of
detective novels born in 1978
she had published 10 books that had
found moderate success
and was living a quiet life without much
to gain the foundation's attention
that is until the foundation started
observing strange events around her
it seemed that whenever miss hastings
read a copy of one of her own books
the events would occur in real life
while some details might change
the main narrative of her book would
play out along with any associated
deaths the foundation picked up on this
pattern when they intercepted uk police
reports
and took a confused miss hastings into
custody
she claimed to be unaware of this
strange effect but cooperated with
foundation authorities and was taken to
site-06
where she was kept in a standard
containment cell but then came the
events of december 14th
2019. it was time for morning checks
and scp-5002 was lying in bed
and she was dead but what had killed her
the cell was locked with no signs of
forced entry
and agent o'connor quickly obtained the
electronic records that showed the cell
had not been disrupted
security cameras confirmed no unusual
activity and the facilities reality
anchors that suppressed reality altering
powers were operational
there was no obvious explanation for
scp-5002's death
but something wasn't adding up agent
o'connor knew she needed to investigate
everyone who could have been involved
soon agent o'connor had collected the
entire crew of site-06
site director evelyn may her chief
medical officer dr nadine grossenbacher
senior researcher dr karen yao and her
second in command michael simpson
security officer lowry and d-class
personnel d-4986
who was currently stationed in wing g
under the supervision of officer lowry
it seemed that after her death scp-5002
had become the star
of her very own detective story the
first meeting of all the suspects was
tense
agent o'connor tried to present the
basics of the case
but it soon descended into arguments
d-4986 had an attitude
and officer lowry wasted no time in
threatening the d-class personnel
junior researcher simpson meanwhile
quickly started showing contempt towards
the deceased miss hastings
referring to her as a neutralized
specimen agent o'connor let them argue
among themselves
watching and studying them before
surprising them all with an
announcement one of the people in this
room was
scp-5002s killer agent o'connor had
already collected much of the material
relevant to the case
she had all the police reports on the
deaths linked to works by scp-5002
including the 2017 unsolved murder of
british grad student kate holloway
she had investigated the containment
cell that scp-5002
had been held in including all the
normal amenities and the unique ones she
had been given
like her electronic typewriter a bottle
of whiskey and a fully typed manuscript
it seemed that scp-5002 hadn't let her
containment stop her writing
now it was time to start interviewing
the suspects starting with
officer lowry officer lowry started out
friendly
but seemed to tense when it came to
discussing the morning he discovered
scp-5002's body
he had been escorting d 4986 who had
been kept in a spare containment chamber
to his standard duties
and checked briefly on the specimens
along the way but when he jiggled the
handle of the cell
and no response came from miss hastings
chamber he investigated
he could see that there was blood all
over the blanket and officer lowry now
accompanied by dr yao
investigated the cell to determine what
had happened
chief medical officer dr nadine
grossenbacher recently promoted to her
position was next to be interrogated
she reported that scp-5002 had been
stabbed at least 10 times by a sharp
object
but there were no signs of a struggle
and no murder weapon was
found in the cell while dr grossenbacher
was helpful in explaining the cause of
death
and in pointing out that the site
director seemed to have a special
interest in scp-5002
she was cagey when asked about her own
whereabouts during the hours of 1
and 3 am the likely time period during
which scp-5002
was killed the picture was not getting
any clearer for agent o'connor
officer lowry was brought back in for
more questioning about the facility's
security systems
it seemed like his shift was well
covered except for a smoke break that he
took around 2 am
where he left every night and left the
low risk containment area
unwatched he had only been gone 15
minutes
and swore that any security breaches
were unlikely due to the need for high
level clearance
lowry continued to cooperate but was
quickly becoming tense at being seen
as a suspect however not everyone was as
cooperative
a security alert soon went up one of the
suspects had tried to leave the facility
it was quickly identified as junior
researcher michael simpson
and his place in the interrogation list
moved up he was belligerent and refused
to give information about why he needed
to leave
and claimed to have an alibi he was
working on his thesis
during the time of the murder he
confirmed officer lowry's story of
trying to rouse scp-5002 in the morning
but claimed to know nothing about a
kitchen knife found in the staff
kitchenette dishwasher
conveniently washed clean of any
identifying substances
agent o'connor may have found the murder
weapon but the killer had covered their
tracks
junior researcher simpson made one thing
very clear
he did not like scp-5002 and was not
particularly sorry she was dead
he viewed all scps the same as inhuman
specimens
unworthy of any respect he had worked
with her extensively in testing
but that didn't seem to change his mind
but he did have kind words for his
supervisor
dr yao who had given him a copy of her
key card
giving him greater access to the
facility agent o'connor decided that she
would need to look a little deeper into
scp-5002's history at the facility
a security video of a previous test of
scp-5002's abilities provided some new
information
and it just so happened to involve dr
yao michael simpson
officer lowry and a new face a female
d-class personnel with a classification
of d2825
the scientists would test scp-5002's
powers by having her write things down
about d2825
and then read them aloud and then watch
as d2825 would act them out
they would primarily test this by using
a machine with two buttons on it
one red and one green 5002 would write
out and then read a passage describing
d2825 pressing a sequence of red and
green buttons to see if she would follow
it
2825 followed the sequence exactly as
scp-5002 had written it
but only once if scp-5002 read it again
there was no effect while it worked when
some of the text was redacted
it seemed to make d2825 deeply upset
and confused as if she was being
puppeted
both scp-5002 and d-2825 were led back
to their cells
but not before scp-5002 asked a
disturbing question
what if d2825 had been restrained when
the text was read
the investigation then shifted to dr yao
who had worked more closely with
scp-5002 than
anyone agent o'connor asked about the
book scp-5002 had written while in
custody
and was told that it was about the life
of a d-class personnel
dr yao said that it had been very
different from her normal works
and ruled out one of agent o'connor's
theories there had been nothing in the
book resembling the events of scp-5002's
death
she had not found a way to
self-neutralize but dr yao did reveal
a few important details the whiskey
found in scp-5002
cell had not been authorized by her and
michael simpson had begun acting cold
and hostile towards scp-5002
several weeks into testing she praised
dr grosenbacher though
and her impressive work with d2825 even
after the d-class suffered a mental
breakdown
but there was one suspect that stood out
in dr yao's mind
and would soon become agent o'connor's
next target
d-4986 had been hostile since the
investigation began
more so than the average d-class dr yao
reported that he had smiled when he had
saw that scp-5002 was dead
and expressed that she got what she had
coming agent o'connor knew
she needed to get the d-class into an
interrogation room
but first she needed more information on
him
starting with finding out why he was in
foundation custody
the incident report wasn't pretty
several murder convictions with three
others suspected
and all 10 deaths were by the same
method brutal
stabbings d 4986 immediately admitted
that he was guilty of those murders and
had no regrets
saying all his victims got what they had
coming but he claimed that he did not
kill scp-5002
despite wanting her dead he had long
hated scp-5002
and dr yao for using him as a puppet
forcing him to perform tasks against his
will
while d2825 had broken down d
4986 was filled with rage
was d 4986 truly innocent or had he been
used against his will
one more time upon examining the
residents of the site
agent o'connor decided to investigate
another potential suspect
a fellow scp better known as robert
gates
this united kingdom-born man's scp
number has been classified
but we know he possessed the ability to
pass through solid objects
and was in foundation custody after
using his ability to assault more than
30 women
believed to be a dangerous criminal with
anti-social personality disorder
he was kept under the influence of a
reality anchor that neutralized his
powers
but had he found a way to break free mr
gates seemed to know more about the
death of scp-5002 than he should
and wasted no time taunting agent
o'connor he claimed to be able to leave
whenever he wanted
despite past testing showing that he was
safely confined
he claimed to be innocent of the murder
and said he never interacted with
or assaulted scp-5002 but he worked
very hard to put doubt in agent
o'connor's mind he wanted them to know
that it was only a matter of time before
he found his way out
there was only one person left who might
be able to provide some
insight about the whole affair director
evelyn may was a busy woman
and she had waited until last to be
interviewed she seemed preoccupied with
other disasters
worried about the paperwork but
cooperated when agent o'connor wanted to
review the data on the reality anchors
for the site
as the interview went on though things
became tense
agent o'connor mentioned that simpson
had been under pressure to produce
results with scp-5002
and director may bristled at the
implications agent o'connor was able to
get information out of director may
about her whereabouts at the time of the
murder though
she had been off-site meeting with a
divorce attorney there was something odd
about that day though
for some reason she only learned
scp-5002 had been killed almost an hour
later than her body was found why had dr
yao kept the events from her boss for so
long
agent o'connor believed she was getting
close to a conclusion
but she needed to dig deeper into dr yao
the senior researcher seemed to have the
closest bond to scp-5000
and a look at a past interview confirmed
this they spent time talking about
scp-5002's new novel
and scp-5002 revealed that she had some
previous awareness of her abilities
before being
apprehended they discussed her plans for
the plot and scp-5002 expressed
overall satisfaction with her living
quarters agent o'connor now had all the
evidence she needed
it was time to gather the suspects after
agent o'connor brought
all the players together she revealed
that she knew they
all had been lying to her everyone
except for d4986
she had pinpointed weak spots in each of
their stories
officer lowry had lied about his smoke
break having been gone longer than he
said
and drinking in addition to smoking when
he realized his drinking on duty would
be discovered
he had stashed the bottle in the one
place he first had the opportunity
scp-5002's sell director main meanwhile
had lied about her motivations
she was being blackmailed she had been
covering up the consistent failure of
reality anchors around the facility
which had allowed a dangerous scp to get
loose
but robert gates's target had not been
scp-5002
it had been the unfortunate d2825
who experienced a breakdown as a result
and the source of the blackmail had been
one of the few other people with access
to the statistics
dr grosenbacher whose quick promotion
suddenly made a lot more sense
dr grossenbacher didn't even know the
full story but agent o'connor
did the reality anchors weren't randomly
malfunctioning
they were targeted none of the other
cells ever malfunctioned
only mr gates's he was placed in close
quarters with scp-5002 with the
intention of him
targeting her by director may or as she
used to be known per a conversation with
her divorce lawyer in london
eve holloway the mother of the late kate
holloway
one of the people who died because of
scp-5002's anomaly
she had been plotting for a long time to
make her suffer
but she wasn't the one who brought the
knife into the facility
agent o'connor then turned to junior
researcher simpson
who had his own agenda his stony and
cold facade was all cover for his
participation in the radical group
known as the serpent's hand which
attempted to liberate scps
he had planned to break into scp-5002's
cell
and liberate her that night giving her
the kitchen knife for protection and
escape with her
simpson was shocked when scp-5002
refused to leave
because she had something keeping her
there she was in love with dr yao
and they were in a relationship and that
was the primary reason she was so
content in her captivity
dr yao was in love with scp-5002
or emma as she called her and had been
intentionally slowing down her research
to ensure she stayed in her facility for
as long as possible
she had been editing the footage to keep
their trysts a secret
and it would have worked if agent
o'connor hadn't noticed the timestamps
while investigating the mysterious case
of the jack daniels bottle
it seemed that there were many people
with ulterior motives
but none of them with a reason to kill
as cp
5002 the pattern of the blood indicated
that scp-5002 had been stabbed standing
up
not in her sleep and then dragged back
to her bed it wasn't an ambush murder
there was likely a confrontation and
after eliminating
all the other suspects agent o'connor
had pieced together the timeline of the
events
junior researcher simpson had made his
attempt to get scp-5002 out of her cell
but she had rejected the escape attempt
in his hurry to avoid detection he had
left the knife behind in the cell and
left the cell door
unlocked just in time for officer lowry
to jiggle the handle as he walked by
and finded a mock he was drunk and he
picked a fight with scp-5002
in the argument the truth came out about
her and dr yao
officer lowry felt she was flaunting it
taunting him
and he couldn't handle it he believed dr
yao should have loved him
not scp 5002 dr yao had always had a
good relationship with lowry
and ignored the signs of trouble on his
profile like
his history of drinking she didn't
realize he was becoming obsessed with
her
and once he lost his mind and stabbed
scp-5002
he did his best to cover it up and he
would have gotten away with it
if it wasn't for the mystery of the jack
daniels bottle
officer lowry was arrested for murder
but agent o'connor
still had questions the final report on
the case would indicate her great doubts
about the outcome
when dealing with a reality warper is
anything as clear-cut as it appears
while the reality anchors in scp-5002
cell were active and there were no texts
detailing the events of her murder
agent o'connor wondered if her ability
could have triggered it
she examined several blank pages found
in the containment cell that had been
cut into an elaborate pattern
she wondered if when they were placed on
the right pages if they could be
some kind of grill cipher revealing a
new meaning while she didn't have any
answers
agent o'connor believed that the
ambiguity of the case possibly warranted
leniency for officer lowry
but she was still left with one big
question
in a world with specimens like scp-5002
who can rewrite reality how much of
anyone's story
is truly their own for more on the
complex nature of the stories of our
lives and how they can be
influenced check out scp-4001
alexandria eternal or watch scp-343-god
for what might be the most powerful
reality warper
in the foundation's custody